um well you know
it's always a good start let's start
with mrs uh bj herself madonna chicony
is her real name
yes i am outraged
what else is new yes i have thought
an awful lot about blowing up the white
house
seems she's obsessed with blowing in
general hey did you see the photographer
in that
shot she was shocked she was
photographed oh damn i wouldn't even say
that white
white white women are crazy some people
are saying did you just do a black voice
oh are you waiting for an apology uh
yeah uh so
nobody expects nobody expects one
madonna was off it was awful
uh if it now i understand the context of
that but if a conservative obviously had
said that this is the obvious
low-hanging fruit of course they'd be at
least
audited if not held out in cuffs or
blamed for the latest benghazi attack
ashley judd not to be outdone by madonna
we have a few clips from her
let's start with clip one and i didn't
know devils could be
resurrected but i feel hitler
in these streets a mustache traded
for a toupee nazis renamed
the cabinet electro-conversion therapy
the new
gas chamber shaming the gay out
of america what
what the electro conversion therapy is
the new
timeline mixed up on that that's like
shutter island what they used to do when
they didn't know what mental illness was
back in the 40s let's just electrocute
him
no he's still [ __ ] throw him in
prison
i don't think she's at the cusp of of
medical innovation
this new fangled penicillin i mean i
don't think she knows
electro conversion therapy is not a
thing but it it it gets worse
why were the female actors paid less
than half
of what the male acts do you mean you i
can guess
even when we do go into higher paying
jobs
our wages are still cut with blades
sharpened by
testosterone i don't think you know what
testosterone is or how it works
it's a hormone it's not a sharpening
stone i i i i don't i don't know
as i drink from the mug that is
was created by estrogen i mean it's not
a good analogy the author's taken some
creative license with it
yeah well this came from a 19 year old
black girl who worked at dunkin donuts
metaphor is not on point do we have one
more
two more two more okay nasty
my blood stains on my bed sheets we
don't actually
choose to have
our periods believe me if we could some
of us would
we don't like throwing away our favorite
pairs of underpants tell me
why are pads and tampax
still taxed oh that was a brand name why
are tampons
and pads still taxed
[Music]
she did doddle a lot on the period thing
she did
she spent a lot of time on the period
thing which makes me think she's on her
period
oh i'm kidding she's too well she's
absolutely barren let's go to clip three
therefore reminding you that our walls
are stronger
than america's ever will be our pleas
are for our pleasure
i love how the audio guy they didn't
even care take care of the mic pop
no like they i mean okay good you're no
one no one can
you're you're is for your pleasure i
i imagine that really it's you've meant
hand
because very few people want to get
anywhere near
that contraption that you call a snatch
okay
i'm just saying it is so unattractive
women don't understand that's the last
clip right oh there's a lot
they've got the women make themselves so
unattractive
they don't like men don't we don't think
you choose your periods
i i don't we don't we don't
we don't we don't want you to we're not
muslim we don't want you to not have
pleasure from your puppy
like we're not competing like uh my wife
didn't have any orgasm for two years
really i'm going for three in high
school
like that's not how it's just it just
paints men with such a
false brush not to be outdone by ashley
judd see what's happening this is called
escalation yeah this crazy broad lit
another one on fire
[Music]
and i love how it took the patriarchy to
put it out yeah he was like putting it
out and you know one of the feminists
was just aching
he ended up using a woman no he's
putting out a fire from one of your
crazy trolls lighting her on fire
not to be outdone by hair lighter on
fire lady
uh you've well you've never heard of the
film snakes in a plane here's
crazy old coots on a plane he has called
me names and insulted me just for
sitting down the seat saying
that i came here to celebrate today you
pretend you have the moral high ground
but you put that man's finger on the
meat of your butt
batman doesn't think
she's so surprised
you mean i can't just treat everybody
like crap
was that tim cook
looked like tim cook mixed with a little
bit of later life steve jobs yeah
um we're gonna get letters so here's the
thing after that the clip she goes
when the guy said you have to get off
the plane she says my
husband's mother died we've noticed that
that's the feminist go to remember we
did that
that gif we did that meme of that
feminist she had a t-shirt that said
i'm a effin feminist and so and this was
uploaded publicly she chose to right on
her facebook and it was used as some
kind of a modeling picture she was by
the way she was a land whale
just so you know and we used it as a
meme for a feminist and then right away
was
my mom's in the hospital take it down i
wrote the feminist film festival i was
like i have
diabetes what does that have to do with
you saying stupid stuff on camera yeah
the socialist video
all the girls like ah i'm sorry i missed
did the whatever i was i was actually
sick last week
yeah yeah i was sick these guys took
advantage of
me praising communism when i had a head
cold
they always go to the victim centers
thinking that it will protect them and
that is one thing i will say about
donald trump
he doesn't allow it to protect them and
that is something that i do love and of
course there is
everyone's favorite protester
at inauguration uh who will now who will
henceforth be known as
not quite a doctor no donald j trump is
now president of the united states
[Applause]
[Music]
and people wonder why this is why we
don't respect you
to be fair to not quite a doctor no she
there she's a track record she's reacted
this way quite a few things yeah i
i believe if i'm not mistaken we have
the archive footage of her
so i'll give her this let's go creed has
confirmed that they will not only tour
this year
but that they have a brand new album on
the way
this is james franco this is anne
hathaway
we're hosting the oscars
if you vote for hillary clinton i will
give you a vote
[Applause]
sony's live-action barbie movie may have
found its leading lady in amy schumer
hey if you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the internet at this
point i'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively
to lotto with credit.com mug club
members if your student military or
veteran entering that promo code it's
less than six dollars a month and you
get daily content no more clips plus
this hand etched mug oh i just when i
feel it i gotta chill like on the inside